[Musique]
à la renaissance
on chante des messes et enchante les
composition polyphonique sur des textes
qui peuvent être drôles aussi noms qui
peuvent exprimer l'amour la souffrance
les émotions la tristesse et cetera la
manière de chanter française était très
à la mode
on aimait la vocalité française le
répertoire français
mais la manière aussi de composer
apprendre le métier de musicien c'était
vraiment une possibilité très bonne pour
survivre dans un monde qui était pas
facile
la chapelle est un groupe de musiciens
qui assure et grant hill ornementations
du culte quotidien de la messe de
l'office par la musique quand le
recrutement des chanteurs pour les
chapelles se faisait par des biais des
ambassadeurs qui vont dans une cour il
écoute quelqu'un qui est très bien et
qui veulent le recruter pour le prince
dans les cours en prince avec un
ensemble de musiciens d'une chapelle du
très haut niveau
eh bien il pourra se présenter à des
rencontres politiques importantes d'une
manière certainement plus favorable que
quelqu'un qui est des pauvres ou de tout
cet entourage pouvoir prêter un tambour
ans à un pape est bien
on pourra voir un retour en termes
politiques économiques donc c'était
aussi une matière des changes par
rapport au pouvoir il y avait des stars
il y avait des compositeurs des
chanteurs qui était particulièrement
réputé et il ya des cas où deux vols
l'un d'eux des musiciens d'une cour à
l'autre il ya quelques musicologue qui a
dit que les chapelles à cette époque
c'était un peu comme les les équipes de
football à nos jours oui le meilleur
était le meilleur payer
[Musique]